Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to Travis
from Manila.
Is this Manila in the Philippines?
Speaker 2: Yes, sir, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Who are you?
You an expat?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm just here for work.
OK.
My question for you.
And thank you for taking my call.
Big fan pleasure considering and forgive me,
I don't have the pole in front of me, but
I just seen a poll that said something like
80 percent of Americans were just completely
done with any or all COVID restrictions.
Yeah.
Would it be wise politically for Democrats
to move in that direction?
Speaker 1: Yes.
And I think that basically they already are.
I mean, I think the Biden White House hasn't
yet really put out anything specific about
like, we're going through the next phase here.
But I think many states are thinking in that
direction, even like I heard from family in
Massachusetts that the school guidelines and
you know, it's a Republican governor in Massachusetts,
but it's a it's, you know, liberal legislature.
They're going in the direction of normalizing
a lot of school staff.
I think I don't think the risk is over to
any degree, but I do think
Speaker 2: that so either, you know, but but
to be clear, politically makes sense.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: You don't think it makes sense
to get rid of guidelines or you don't think
it makes sense to keep them.
Speaker 2: I don't I don't think it makes
sense to keep them
Speaker 1: right, yeah.
No, I'm increasingly of that mindset and part
of it is with cases going down so rapidly
and the belief that we're moving into the
endemic phase endemic doesn't mean mild necessary,
necessarily.
You can have something that's endemic and
serious.
It's just a question of like we were talking
about with Vincent Racaniello two weeks ago.
What milestone are we waiting for in terms
of Omicron is we're well beyond the peak and
masking and vaccines are widely available.
Everybody sort of knows at this point the
level of risk that you have.
It's a question of like, what's the next milestone
we're waiting for if we don't start easing
off of stuff now and making things more kind
of personal decisions?
Speaker 2: What do you think the answer to
that question is?
Speaker 1: I mean, I think it's if there is
another variant that makes cases spike and
it's not significantly milder, like if the
next variant truly is just a cold, then I
think we don't do anything.
But if there's a new variant that is just
as dangerous as the ones that we've had, you
probably put some guidelines back on is my
sense.
Speaker 2: OK, I appreciate the time, David,
thank you very much.
Speaker 1: My pleasure, thank you so much
for the call.